with hundreds of shows hitting the small
screen each year there are bound to be
some strange ones that slipped under the
radar and a few that will have you
wondering how they were ever made in the
first place here are some of the most
bizarre TV shows you won't believe
actually exist Vanilla Ice goes Amish if
you've been hoping to find a TV show in
which a dress down vanilla ice moves in
with the Amish the DIY Network has got
you covered in 2013's appropriately
titled home improvement spin-off Vanilla
Ice goes Amish the rapper assists his
Pennsylvania Dutch hos with a variety of
tasks around the house the rest of the
time he basically just sits on the porch
tells jokes and does everything but
embrace the Amish lifestyle if that
isn't good television
what is the Swan reality TV has really
scraped the bottom of the barrel a few
times and you'd be hard-pressed to find
a better example than the Swan a
two-season beauty pageant featuring
so-called ugly ducklings who receive
extensive plastic surgery life coaching
and psychological therapy and
surprisingly some contestants were left
both physically and emotionally scarred
and the show has rightfully been
chastised for exploiting women with
pre-existing personal issues no matter
which way you tried to spin it the Swan
was ugly exploitative and just plain
awful
thankfully the planned celebrity Swan
revival never made it to the air
Ramez in control Egypt's rahmatan
control is like Punk'd on steroids
well-known television prankster Ramez
gala isn't afraid to take things to the
absolute extreme he once gave socialite
Paris Hilton the ride of her life by
staging an emergency airplane landing
though speculation has arisen that she
was in on the prank all along according
to CNN gala ones ran a prank or dramas
such as a fox in which he and a group of
armed men hijacked a bus before
kidnapping and blindfolding the
passengers yikes the puppy Channel long
before videos of keyboard playing cats
were only a few clicks away
there was a short-lived television pilot
called the puppy Channel according to
upvotes it actually tested well - with
38% of one focus-group a claiming that
probably watch it at least once per day
unfortunately the puppy channel never
did become its own full-fledged channel
but at least we still have Puppy Bowl
sunset days in 2010 we TV launched her
own geriatric Jersey Shore in the form
of
today's a reality show featuring baby
boomers gone wild according to the LA
Times the show is a success among older
viewers at the end of 50 demographic
family shows many aged to find
one-liners cheesy and the first episodes
discussions regarding going commando
struck many as cringe-worthy as a result
the show was put out to pasture after
only one season Prince of poets Abba
dabbas competition show Prince of poets
focuses on wannabe words miss for citing
their best lines to an enthusiastic
crowd and panel of judges unlike the
United States where poets are largely
confined to open mic nights and coffee
shops the Arab world really digs its
poetry poets and some parts of the
Middle East a bonafide pop stars filling
stadiums with eager ears excited to hear
some verbal bliss cop rock have you ever
found yourself watching a cop show like
the shield of Blue Bloods and wishing it
was actually a musical probably not but
if you have definitely check out 1990s
musical police drama cop rock ABC's
bizarre cross genre show only lasted 11
episodes and has since found its way
onto more than his fair share of worst
TV shows of all time lists but no one
can deny the fact that the show is a lot
of fun to laugh with and laugh at the
show also deserves credit for trying
something new in the industry full of
recycled ideas after all when's the last
time you've seen a singing baby merchant
on TV The Flying Nun it's hard to
imagine a major network of green
lighting a show about a Flying Nun
what's even harder to believe is that
such a show would make it through more
than 80 episodes of Flying Nun ad on ABC
from 1967 to 1970 and featured Sally
Field as a novice nirn whose small frame
and stiff cornets made a susceptible to
gusts of wind as one might expect the
comedy is fairly mediocre in fact as
feel told Oprah Winfrey in 2008 she
didn't even want to do the show
fortunately she transcended the
ridiculous role and went on to enjoy a
long award filled acting career thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]